I'm back with another interesting tip
using hydrogen peroxide now most people
have hydrogen peroxide sitting in their
medicine cabinet in a little brown
bottle and it's usually like a 3% you
may have a food grade hydrogen peroxide
which you could also use too but your
white blood cells actually make hydrogen
peroxide
as a defense mechanism to kill off
invading bacteria funguses parasites
ease Candida so basically what it does
is it oxidizes the layer of microbes
okay so it destroys the cell wall of
invading microbes now when we produce
hydrogen peroxide in our bodies we have
various enzymes to dismantle it as well
but hydrogen peroxide will then turn
into h2o plus oxygen and there's other
types of oxidizing compounds that are
created as a by-product from this that
will help sterilize the area I'm not
going to get into those all you need to
know is that you can use hydrogen
peroxide for various things
if you cut yourself to clean the area
you can put some hydrogen peroxide on it
it bubbles up and it kills up the
microbes
also you can gargle with it
one tablespoon which is 15 grams of
hydrogen peroxide 260 grams or four
tablespoons of water what you do is you
would drink it swish it around the mouth
don't swallow it but you can gargle with
it if you have a sore throat you can
just swish it in your mouth for 30
seconds to kill off and cleanse the
microbes in your mouth and you can use
it for many other things from removing a
stain that you have on your clothing and
you can even use it to clean your
vegetables you take a half a cup of
hydrogen peroxide mix it with two cups
of water
let your vegetables soak in it for a few
minutes rinse it off and you have some
clean vegetables anyway I just wanted to
create this quick video on hydrogen
peroxide and I wanted you to comment
below on your experience with hydrogen
peroxide so if you want more knowledge
on how to create a healthy body
subscribe now and get daily
notifications